じゃあみんな肇社長だよ動画の一番最初のコメントを当てようとするゲームをやったん
だけどあの
マヂ無理全然当たんねーし動画あの十三触れない1時間以上取ってたんですが高くなっ
たしも編集もめんどくさがった猫は飼っ
になっちゃったよ全然まだ見てない人は全米から見れたよ
では後半どうぞよ演技表情の大切さがとてもわかる動画このシリーズ好き
いわば涙うんそれだと思うなんかよっちが面白かったんだよねはい
ん
いいいいいい
すっげー good の数だねこの bg も使えばどんな動画でも面白くなる説
はい今日は the が出た3曲
に持ちで打っていくよはい
聞かれてるみたいだ今日早く見ます次へでもいいがまずびっくりやばいよ日本よ
始めたちょっと当たっちゃうねかはじめいいパパになりそう
俺もそう願いたいところ赤ちゃんの可愛い
はい
幸せな気分になるねまあでスマートフォンからも何よりでございます本当に音の僕性の
ある動画だといけそうですね
人の乳首を吸いことができるサイコロ機もいいか面白いの入ったけどな
ていません
マサキと中でやってくださいときなあっはい
ヨッチガチって言ったところが自分軟調で行っません
4つうれしそうとかしライブで風呂をつくってみた確かにこれはねなんだろうなぁ
どっちだろうこれはマジで後片付け大変そう
緑だから気持ち悪いいきましょう次に行ってもう
iphone をテンペラにされたらどう反応するのか唐津へが反応面白い系もあると
思うしこのネターの発想自体をもせる
どっちに転ぶかだねシンプルでかわいいとやられたらキレるああ
あー俺も切れますわーうんまず分10分者本人じゃないかありえない高額な駐車料金が
請求されたときこれは大変だった千浦企画がこれが今回親コメントしそうだぞ
介護やる公約強いとしたら
マジで腰ぬけたてびっくりしました見てみますよ
[音楽]
引っ越しば引っ越すが嬉しいなベイビー広告人にか謎な買うとコッシーのショートや
刷毛これツイッターで腰のアカウントがば安いのがあってそれの正体を暴くという動画
なんですけどもぼくコッシーだと思います
ああそうな間違いない少しフォローしてきたアレアレは呼吸か16万こういう形で
決まったロブ例えばだめよ
名前部留学名前見せたってどういうことが起こっシーっていう名前だったんじゃないか
な人もと音 c こっから前でみょず名前逆になるかなぁ
ああっジャイロっぺになってるけどなるとこれを生きる
んじゃねーかな怪しすぎるアカウント謎の家の正体を暴きます
わんまんでしょこれあー絶対は何度も言っ殺す取ったら謎のいるほどどっちかだと思い
ます
オチまで作る完璧な謎読めないとこれ本当に斉藤さんはじめした張本人だとバレるのか
本人がやるとは思わないよね
あーなるほどねー最近斉藤さんやってる人
グッドボタンまたであたりは語れよ
斉藤さんしてくれた皆さんありがとうございました
いよいよやばいよねサイレントはじめの部屋全く喋らない動画なんですけども
またこの企画やってほしい
[音楽]
とび笑笑笑笑なるほどに行ってろ人物
わあああああっ
by 前寝てる人を起こさずに電球でテニスとミックさん優しい次次のオリンピックの
種目にしてください
胎教30m と羽根が飛び出るポテチ物を作っていたのに入るもんだ
ああポテチ食べたくなった
[音楽]
そうたぶんこのコメントが99%の人に読まれずにスルーされると思いますでも呼んで
くれた1%の人々て今週も頑張っていこう
俺の家の階段をた気にしてみた片付ける対戦君の名は見たい人
グッドボタンわー最初に氷見の7話知ったんですよ
えっ
ブーブー
わーコンビのタボ37番を決めましょう
ツナサンドの方が好き結局セブンイレブンが選挙を
タマゴタケに税率がぐいってか裏技
言われたいいや全面で食ってみた
これも当該お部屋とかながいろんなメンツであったんですけど最強のメンバー
1コメブーブー透明客くってみた前編はじめ桑名すぎ
うわぁみたらダメって食べたことだったして
ん
4馬房へ2わー
これは2012年
5年前はそんなにやってとか youtube
もう5年尾根や内で5年前の動画でてと先日激辛ペン国でソースをかけるドッキリ
二人とも若いんだよ正木強くねみたいなるほどねあら犬んです
すっごい
この頃から殲滅のお姉だったのかたバッハ
舌熱い乗り物酔いしない俺がいせで超回転した結果
汚いってコメントが降らない
ame
[音楽]
とって者前でこれ
ん
がんばっはぁ
まあかっこいいんじゃないですかこれ私が水を何リットル飲めば臭いが来るのかも
ほんと前を列記じゃないますよ俺は汚いでしかないですよ
汚いにそう言ってないじゃないかかっこいい
動か泊国とか俺ちゃんとコメントしてよところ里のでないですねを持っている巨大な
蜘蛛相手に行ってきた
これで試し来ない
自分の見た目より重くて運ぶの大変だっ
クロパパっ派
これどちらもねえなどくどく生紫色の巨大なクマがやってきた
おかあ寂しくないねところ the よりダークですハアァ
はじめの避ける5月5層ありがとう
帰ってきたらベイマックスがいるドッキリなんか黒神珍しいで見たいなあー
感じだと思いますよあんまり黒亀してないかな米 max まだ見てない
どっちかあたってくれたらばはい
さあ黒が見たいぞ金髪にこちらは私を助けてありがとうござい
みんなグル紙でいることにするよ
pon
[音楽]
me
あぶね一歩間違えたら思っなったじゃこれ